[Music]
tell me about what you're wearing
because this is wardrobe Tommy Hilfiger
I mean my first teen choice yeah yeah
you got your man here you just got so
high soon as you start talking about
shoes he was here when he was younger we
were looking at his pictures and he's
wearing like Abercrombie I'll be in
pitch yet not not anymore
yeah you've been here years ago this is
her first one did you give her any Teen
Choice Awards advice just have fun how
does it feel for you guys to hit a
carpet together like do you know how to
pose together yet do you gush over each
other what do you do usually I would go
with my dad so now my dad is still on
the car boot but he's taking pictures of
us and he's gonna make a cute collage
for Instagram but it's so nice having
him I feel way less nervous and
[Music]
I know you've delayed the release of the
album right can you talk to us a little
bit about that yes
I just keep writing songs in my
management and my label both agreed like
we can't just stop here we can't just
put it put out what we have we have to
let you keep writing so too creative
right now I wondered if it was a wedding
that was delaying no no that lots of
Christmas hopefully last question any
message for Demi Lovato she's nominated
but of course not able to be no we love
you themI you're so strong we know
you'll come back stronger than ever and
I can't wait for a return
[Music]